i always love your music intro
all right cooking confidence coach nanny
bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive of course the
sponsors of this segment today we are
learning how to make long life noodles
and chicken and it's all about lunar new
year i love it look at this beautiful
display all the red is so gorgeous on
the white isn't it so winter new year
began on tuesday february 1st it
actually lasts for a full two weeks
wonderful but the traditions are just
specific to the first three days so
today it ends as far as the heavy
traditions and i love family i love
tradition i love custom and so the way
that the chinese actually celebrate the
lunar new year is amazing so as and
through a lot of food yeah yeah so you
mentioned this what is that are we
eating
no it's a broom so you don't sweep
during the first three days because you
will be sweeping out your luck i like
that you don't wash your hair for the
first three days because you don't want
to wash away your your luck one of the
things you don't take the trash out
right for the first three years smelly
in my apartment you can sleep but don't
take out what you sweat for three days
okay okay here's the one that i think
you're going to like the best always buy
a pair of new shoes and wear them on the
first day and why so that you step into
a good year well i wish you would have
told me that
because i would have gladly bought shoes
you know because i'm chinese new year
there you go okay why i drove egg rolls
because they resemble gold bars did you
make these uh no i didn't okay no shrimp
because it's a hononym for laughter and
shrimp is you know great these shiitake
mushrooms resemble gold coins okay so
that's it we are gonna i know it's
wonderful so you eat them these are the
things that you eat and love and enjoy
during the lunar new year brings you
good fortune here's something new that
i've just learned let's do it it's
called velveting your protein this is
corn starch
a little bit of white pepper
velveting your protein yeah there you go
a little bit of salt and what we're
going to do is well spread salt all over
like butter right it was that accident
but then again and we've got a broom
don't worry don't worry but don't sweep
it out
[Laughter]
so we're just going to cover this in
cornstarch and then set it aside and you
let it sit for about 10 minutes in the
refrigerator and then we're going to
come back and throw it in and show you
what to do with it so
um to start will you blanch okay and you
julian blanching i don't have time to
teach you okay i was gonna ask what is
blanching manny
throwing it in hot water boiling water
and then throwing in a nice bath i'm
gonna teach you that next week this week
i'm gonna teach you julianning which
these all are and it's just simply
cutting your vegetables like matchsticks
do you see that so nice and long and
what we're going to do is just let me
heat this up a little bit more
and these are long life noodles and
chicken so why the long life long life
is that the noodles the longer they are
the longer the life isn't great
we're going to throw in the noodles and
just like a stir fry we're going to
throw in
all the vegetables which is
carrots
snow peas red
red peppers bean sprouts we're going to
start sauteing it up i lost track of
where i was i always love making a
stir-fry because it just kind of gets
fun throwing stuff in there yes anything
goes yes
and we're going to stir it up we're
going to keep it now this isn't just
a wok but it's something that i had that
i felt was close enough and resembled it
okay so and a wok is a traditional
asian
bowl asian uh pan pan okay yeah yeah so
now as this is heating up what we are
going to do is take the chicken right
here okay which we would let it rest for
about 10 minutes but in the interest of
time we're going to do it let's see if
this is hot enough
and what you want to do with your
protein is you just want it to cook
until it gets white okay so i'll let
this i just put it up real high on eight
and i just want to show you exactly what
you do but in the interest of time and
health
i actually made very well cooked chicken
because i know you all love to eat that
afterwards we're going to throw that in
always come prepared we're going to take
um the long life noodles if you want to
throw those in for me i can just throw
them in just throw them in there we go
very
cheers
very chinese we're going to put in 15
million we've got 30 seconds oyster
sauce
oh i know that is a magic touch right
oil it is a little bit of soy sauce
a little bit of sugar you see that we're
just throwing right and that's sugar add
sugar a little secret ingredient just a
teaspoon right and we're going to i'm so
good and this is so hearty and healthy
too i love this and beautiful and now
we're ready to actually
throw it onto the platter or do you want
to just eat it from here okay chocolate
let's throw it on let's throw it on and
let's go to the
still so i can tell everybody how to
make this or how to get the information
okay online oh my gosh there you go look
how gorgeous this is
beautiful bon appetit i'm gonna go ahead
and just save this for myself
check out nanny bobby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment this is amazing thank you thank
you so much thank you jillian that
smells so good in here i can't wait to
try some of that